I'm kelcie cook and I'm a stand-up
comedian and world champion foosball
player my parents met while competing in
a pro foosball tournament so I've been
playing since I was a toddler I decided
it was time to merge the two biggest
parts of my life and start playing
foosball against some of the most
competitive shit-talking people I know
comedians this is wrists of Fury hey
everybody welcome to wrists of Fury I'm
Kelsey cook and today I'm so excited to
destroy Jay Larson and booth ball I'm
excited because I've never played a
professional in a sport before in
anything no how many people have played
a professional like you roll a new pool
home I know who's Fats Domino well I'm
stoked to play you have you what's your
first ball experience minimal minimal
like if you didn't know a kid who had
one of these growing up you were just
like you're out and it's one of those
things like yeah I could do this and
then you show up and then I've seen
clips of you I'm just like good lord
so let me ask you this when you were
growing up how many tournament how often
were you playing foosball all the time
there are pictures of me when I'm like 2
years old standing on a stool with like
my mom's hands over my hands like
teaching me how to I'm playing with the
Tiger Woods of foosball right now but I
mean there's part of me that's like I
think I can beat her oh yes every dude
that comes in here it's like a bar game
you know anyway like if you walked in
you saw a professional and our play
she's like I got it and then you're just
like oh no maybe I don't so I turned at
all by this all those all your titles
yeah I mean why is there a soccer ball
cuz if table soccer okay is that a
tornado over there yeah yeah I know can
we appreciate how white trash like all
the flames first of all you're a
professional foosball player there's
nothing more white trash than that I
know I'm very proud of it
regulation so we're gonna play one game
to five just a first game just get the
hang of this real quick okay comfortable
get comfortable losing is this a pro
table this is a pro table this is a
warrior it's a very very high-end a nice
table do you know like the basic rules
like no spinning
oh you can't spin yeah and this this
streetrat I brought in here usually
you'd be able to like put the ball in
through here but we start it in the
middle okay close it's okay with you you
just mmm nope not up to it you're okay
that's good recognition standard which
way am i shooting I'm shooting that way
oh my god this is gonna be bad okay you
might want to know a that's fine I just
think you should put it to where like
you can touch it oh I get I start off
with that yeah okay yeah yeah chill out
you know I like I'm not cocky in any
other area of life but this is the one
area that I enjoy yeah well I wouldn't
get too cocky oh yeah you just spun my
guy you got it you I get the ball back
yes here yeah I know I mean I have an
idea but are you just like teasing right
now oh come on yeah baby felt that to
some Maryland offense right there
Oh does that count I put it in though Oh
baby whoa any way you can get it take
your point [ __ ] take your [ __ ]
eye on asleep l like you did that like
that was something your parents did to
you growing up and they're like just
bounce one off the wall and put it in
your own net I think I'm right before
that you're like but you squirt on me in
and I'm like yeah you can screw on
yourself though you are
oh geez it's fine that felt like you
might have spend it oh you thought I
spun it I don't know I'm just saying
maybe if somewhere we go to replay and
find out like oh it wasn't spin it
wasn't it just seemed like it was going
pretty quick that's all that's just I
mean just that's what it seemed by the
way I'm playing to my left here I don't
know no see you know now normally would
you have been able to grab over there
and get end that yeah relax with those
yeah well you said okay I mean it's just
a little much it's just not as
hospitable as I would have liked you
know what I mean I know what you think
you walked into that I was gonna be
super friendly with I mean look at that
trophy right there that's some like pool
hall that wasn't so that was the first
game you got one point I grab cilantro
off the wall I think at one point that I
didn't put in just a quick basil break
all right
well I mean that's just a warm-up round
so
alright okay so you come over here we're
gonna do some handicaps trying to help
you out a little bit
okay all right we roll this around okay
you pick it oh I get one too yeah okay
what she got I start with three points
opponents starts with three points okay
I got [ __ ]
hand come baby we've done that one yeah
okay so I have to play handcuff you can
I get three point you can't even put it
in the hole here it bounces whatever so
you are starting with three three we're
playing a five plane to five and I have
to play handcuffs okay so like you had a
foosball table in your basement I take
it yeah and like was it just like
hardcore like with the first time you
beat your mom what did she not talk to
you for like a month I can't remember
the first time but I do know that when
she and I go to the major tournaments
then we have to play women's singles
almost every time at some point in the
bracket we have to play each other and
it like alternates each tournament like
I'll beat her and then she beats me and
then I beat her again and it's like you
know it's bittersweet cuz that first
show oh yeah like I beat you and then
it's like it's your mom that's it then
you're lazy yeah this is uncomfortable
and that's crazy a little bad all right
well okay I'll let you start the ball
even though you're deeply advantaged
yeah I should be I'm playing a
professional all right all right
you ready yeah this is so uncomfortable
that's you oh man you're gonna get
smoked baby hey it's worth it just to
see you little Triceratops yeah whatever
[Music]
Triceratops sounds like a vegetable PS
it does get in there what does this move
so you don't hit your men yeah give
yourself alright when are you from New
York so you don't hit your man don't hit
your men Oh baby
okay no okay [ __ ] how frustrated people
watching me right now they're like oh my
god would you just do something no no
okay would you stop like you're climbing
a mountain
dear you see that shot though you suck
get in
yeah what's up defense I can't even
stand that you can pass the dudes stop
stop yeah that's good D right there LC
[Laughter]
to bottom that's what they call it top
to bottom I forgot that you started oh
no you started with three points so you
just need one more
oh it you've only scored two yeah yeah
so played soccer all growing up started
like at five did any of your soccer
skills translate to this you feel like
no nothing no hand-eye coordination yeah
well I mean hand I would have been like
it like I like I'm pretty good at like
pool and darts for a guy who doesn't
play pool or darts yeah but I don't uh
this is like a lot of moving around you
got to know your soccer is more like
foot nine coordination you just gotta
get that one door but yeah and timing
and athlet you know this isn't really
like athletic ability you know what I
mean this is like a hobby
oh okay see how do you how does yours
not like when you go back and forth it
doesn't just slide down like mine just
did oh I think so baby come come that we
do you can just grab it if it oh boy oh
boy okay alright come on
getting so flustered here I feel like
I'm playing like the two of the trombone
we just relax with then you could just
put it in you're like blasting to get
your dent like just gonna like throw
like I guess you're playing better DD
than you were the first time so I got to
be careful like how did I just lose that
cuz you're not pushing it forward after
you move it back and forth no no you
this is for for us this is it if I score
then it's over
would you stop yes with handcuffs
[ __ ] I mean it's pretty crazy
it's crazy but impressive I and I like I
appreciate getting whooped because you
should thank you I mean it would be sad
if I was losing right I mean I don't
know I mean no one really considers us a
professional sport anyway okay Jason so
anytime you can like call a timeout in a
sport to grab wings well we have a cool
thing to help you is that my mom who's
in the Football Hall of Fame and you get
to FaceTime with her and get some tips
hi okay so I just beat Jay barely it was
close
hey mom so mom you're gonna talk to Jay
gonna give Jason tips and help him out a
little bit first of all who's to say I
can't even trust you you think I'm
trusting this family lineage what's the
basic thing I need to know I can move
quick from pretzel rod to pretzel rod
when I play against a person if they're
faster than I am but you can play
conservative and try and slow it down no
listen you got to get a little more
basic than this I'm not slowing anybody
down you gotta just give me hey bro you
know chlorine in her eyes or something
like that okay listen this is a family
program you settle down with touching
rods
good lord oh my god
she's crazy in 65 yards throwing out
hand job joke she's dead she said okay
so you do have a chance though to win
everything because this is sudden death
final round we're gonna play two ball
two ball we each have one each have one
you have to score both in order to get a
point we're just gonna play two three
okay so here's the thing
if you lose you have to show the camera
your [ __ ] stamp Wow
saying that deflategate is real and the
Patriots cheated first of all you don't
get someone into an event and they'll be
like Oh PS you want to moralize your
whole belief system no and what happened
if I win you get a pic first of all I'm
probably gonna lose - there's no way I
haven't scored once and now I got a
score twice - just get one point but I
have this card tries to I'll show my
[ __ ] stamp but I don't believe in
deflategate and I'm standing by it
I'll leave my pride at the door with the
I got a tattoo at a time when [ __ ]
stands word a thing okay women but I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna say deflategate
was a thing we can just edit it from
what you just said just now and it will
just be deflategate was the thing
deflategate was a thing all right you
ready 1 2 3
I should be able to spin do you want to
be able to spin
I'll let you spend for this just chill
out with this just chill out with that
okay 1 2 3
[Applause]
don't don't hold that thing over there
thank you get over here this time
oh [ __ ] yeah doesn't count still in it
go J's remix into ball oh thanks [ __ ]
what all right note it she she put her
hand on I don't know about that I'll get
the rulebook out oh man Oh get the
rulebook out on you starting it on your
forward you big cheat like two balls off
okay
what's the split okay can we please look
at what he's doing this is it needs to
be so we have to level the playing field
you're a disgrace to the sport that's
your comfort zone as the spin what's the
only thing
oh my god haven't played against
somebody who's fun in the water this is
another level all right it's a wash
again excited oh my god am i able to use
that little thing that you guys put in
there boom baby
these in it two to one
that's dirty you're dirty blisters is
the only way you're gonna get buyers
we're old lady we have this dirty I got
to end this now enough of this nonsense
oh my god who saw that see you guys get
that in the camera oh it's a dead spot
oh my god I'm literally sweating nope
nope too fancy I'll pull this trigger
take off that shirt but like I said it
was a different time they weren't called
a [ __ ] stamp yet I thought it was a
good place it's a psilocybin mushroom
what is slit sweets is that German for
come shop what is that that slits
veidt's okay and it's gnome okay and I
believe if you have mushrooms you can go
live with gnomes okay it was a long time
ago oh my god that is embarrassing yeah
well thank you for coming and letting me
just feel so good about myself
you rock I mean that's impressive [ __ ]
yeah thank you thank you never gotten my
ass to play a pro in anything before
yeah awesome see you next time on recipe
right